Philippe Martinez bonjour merci d'être
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué CGT chez Renault près de 3000
suppressions de postes 1000
reclassements internes en 97 en France
ce sont des chiffres que vous nous
confirmez maintenant nous avons eu
l'information ce matin c'est 3800
suppressions d'emploi qui vont être
annoncés au Comité central entreprise le
13 mars
quitter l'entreprise finalement un
chiffre équivalent à l'année qui vient
de s'écouler je crois que il faut bien
parler de 3800 suppression d'emplois
parce que ça va concrétiser
par 3000 filles et 800 pardon
suppression d'emploi donc c'est bien de
ça qu'il faut parler c'est pas 600 ce
sont des mesures qui vont empêcher des
jeunes de rentrer en entreprise puisque
il n'y aura pas d'embauche et c'est cela
devrait toucher plusieurs sites d'après
vos informations où on pourrait
envisager la fermeture d'une seule
entreprise mais tous les sites sont
concernés par ce plein de suppression
d'emploi
à la grève générale la CGT a déjà avec
d'autres organisations syndicales
françaises belges et espagnol appelé une
journée de mobilisation le 6 mars qui
sera prolongé le 7 mars dans certaines
dans certains établissements je crois
que nous allons tout faire le mouvement
ce sont les salariés qui vont décider il
y a une forte émotion dans l'entreprise
suite à l'annonce de la fermeture de
Vilvorde et aujourd'hui au plan social
donc nous allons tout faire pour
utiliser le personnel en accord avec eux
on a quand même le sentiment on parle de
l'échec de l'Europe sociale mais on a
tout de même le sentiment que les que
les syndicats français sont restés assez
timides quand même dans leur soutien à
porter au salarié belge une heure de
d'arrêt de travail vendredi prochain
dans toutes les entreprises je crois que
nous avons réagi tout de suite à cette
annonce de fermeture en montrant bien
que nous voulions avec le personnel
français nous mobilisé par rapport aux
problèmes français mais y compris avec
les salariés belges cette décision d'une
heure de grève c'est une première étape
puisque dès la semaine prochaine il y
aura d'autres manifestations et compte
tenu de l'état d'esprit du
mécontentement qui Achères Renault je
crois que les salariés peuvent décider
avec leurs organisations syndicales des
Jeudis d'autres formes de grève alors on
l'a rappelé dans le reportage le
gouvernement la semaine dernière à
refusé d'accorder des départs empereur
traite donc ça concernait Renaud Peugeot
à peu près 40 000 départs de prêtres
vous pensez que Renaud n'évitera pas les
licenciements secs je crois que cette
décision de plan social est prise avec
la complicité du gouvernement on essaie
d'opposer la décision de -40000 avec
l'annonce d'aujourd'hui je crois que le
gouvernement est parfaitement complice
de ces décisions puisque premièrement il
est actionnaire principal avec 46% du
capital de Renault et que il l'annonce
ses fêtes juste après celle du Conseil
des ministres qui vont monsieur Bora
disait qu'il refusait le prendre des
-40000 je crois que c'est une décision
qui a été prise en commun avec le
gouvernement Philippe Martinez je vous
remercie
[Musique]